Gun laws have just been relaxed in the country
with one of the world's highest homicide rates.
Brazil's far-right president Jair Bolsonaro
is reversing earlier, strict regulations that
essentially prevented civilians from bearing
firearms.
In order to guarantee them (the citizens)
this legitimate right of defense, I, as president,
will use this weapon.
The decree opens up gun ownership to adults
over 25 living in rural areas or high crime
urban areas.
They must have no criminal record, and a gun
club course is obligatory.
In a country that saw almost 64 thousand homicides
in 2017, Bolsonaro's hardline law and order
platform has won him support from those who
see wider gun ownership as a better way to
protect themselves.
The new decree could increase violence but
at least it gives a chance to citizens to
defend themselves, if they are victims and
depend on police who aren't doing the job
they should.
A recent poll by the Datafolha company though
suggests most Brazilians support the previous
restrictions on gun ownership.
They fear more guns will mean more danger:
It's very clear in the decree that everybody
that lives in the country may have now the
right to own 4 guns.
WEISSBLITZ It's an expansion of a license
to kill, that was seen before.
I think that easing gun ownership is not good.
I don't think that's the way we will improve
the situation in Brazil, it's not with fire
against fire.
For now, Brazililan police and military are
still the only ones allowed to bear arms in
PUBLIC.
The big fear for many critics is that it might
not be long before Bolsonaro allows civilian
gun owners to join them.